donc bonjour et bienvenue pour ce point
presse et nous allons évoquer dans un
premier temps puisque le gouvernement se
complaît à ne pas répondre
la situation de calais nous allons
certainement être obligés dé revenir
toutes les semaines si monsieur valls
monsieur cazeneuve et le président de la
république ne donne toujours pas
répondre aux attentes des français par
rapport à cette situation dont je vous
rappelle à quel point elle est
catastrophique
nous étions à moins de 900 migrants sur
le site dit de la jungle à calais avant
nous sommes aujourd'hui en fonction des
comptages divers et variés entre neuf et
onze mille personnes
nous avons rappelé la semaine dernière
que le gouvernement en catimini avait un
plan pour faire en sorte que ces
personnes dont je rappelle que leur
souhait absolue et d'aller en angleterre
puisse être envoyé sur un certain nombre
de territoires en france le premier
ministre ici hier a indiqué que la
situation juridique de ces personnes
seraient étudiées à l'issue de leur
installation dans différents endroits de
france nous insurgeons contre cela
considérant comme ça se fait partout en
europe que la situation de ces personnes
qu'ils soient réfugiés économiques ou
réfugié politique et évidemment s'il
s'agit de réfugié politique
il faut leur donner baudroie à rester
sur leur territoire national doit être
étudiée dès leur arrivée et certainement
pas une fois qu'ils auront été six mois
huit mois un an
installés sur le territoire national il
faut de façon très claire que des
hotspots soient créées aux frontières de
l'union
et en l'espèce aux frontières de l'union
à l'intérieur du dispositif dont est
sorti l'angleterre ce hotspot doit être
créé en angleterre
nous demandons quand françois hollande
daignera aller en angleterre rencontrer
madame theresa may pour enfin enfin
trouver une solution à ce problème qui
est absolument majeur est dramatique
nous craignons d'ailleurs au regard du
climat
assez détestable qui est en train de se
mettre en place sur le pays avec des
affrontements qui ont l'air de se
dessiner entre un certain nombre
d'associations et des no border qui sont
venus perturber des réunions où on
explique l installation de personnes
d'origines migrantes
nous nous demandons dans quelle mesure
le gouvernement ne devrait pas saisir
cette occasion pour vraiment resituer
recentrer le débat
ces gens veulent partir en angleterre
ils souhaitent s'installer
économiquement en angleterre
nous exigeons que une discussion ait
lieu entre notre président de la
république monsieur françois hollande et
les instances anglaises
depuis plusieurs mois nous appelons à
réengager une renégociation de schengen
en faveur d'un chêne gagnent deux camps
le gouvernement va-t-il nous répondent à
nous les répliques 1 mais surtout
répondre aux français
merci beaucoup à vous chers valérie le
on souhaitait tous les deux revenir
aussi en ce lundi matin sur le week-end
très chargé
non pas du gouvernement plutôt aux
abonnés absents mais du parti socialiste
on a comme tous nos compatriotes et
concitoyens vu combien la primaire du
parti socialiste commencé à intéresser
les membres du parti socialiste
chacun y est y est allé de sa propre
candidature et nous ce que nous voulons
dire c'est plutôt que de présenter leur
candidature à la primaire du parti
socialiste
c'est personnalités éminentes du parti
social serait mieux de présenter leurs
excuses au peuple français
compte tenu de l'échec considérable de
leur politique menée depuis 2012 entre
d'un côté françois hollande le président
de l'impuissance publique devenu
candidat de l'indécence entre emmanuel
macron pour reprendre les mots d'alain
juppé qui est devenu le le candidat de
l'incompétence et de la déloyauté et on
oubliera pas et je pense que les
français le savent que le cadeau de
départ de monsieur macron du
gouvernement vu 50 mille chômeurs de
plus au mois d'août
plus d'un million de chômeurs sous le
règne de françois hollande et de
monsieur macron depuis 2012 donc il est
important de le rappeler
plutôt que de donner des leçons de
morale à la terre entière
comme il le répète avec une certaine
gourmandise nous pourrions aussi évoqué
le ministre de l'insécurité avec
monsieur 15,9 et sa nouvelle conseillère
en sécurité publique anne hidalgo qui
préfère parler de camp de naturistes à
paris ou d'interdire les voitures plutôt
que d'assurer la sécurité des parisiens
et ce qui s'est passé encore cette nuit
avec
kim kardashian le démontre aisément
qu'il est urgent pour l'image de la
france pour le rayonnement international
de la france est entre autres pour notre
rayonnement touristique d'assurer la
sécurité des parisiens qui doit
redevenir une priorité nathalie kosciuko
morizet a évoqué ce matin avec beaucoup
de justesse
il est indispensable que qu'anne hidalgo
s'empare à nouveau en lien avec le
gouvernement de la sécurité des
parisiens et nous pourrions évidemment
poursuivre et fils et ses métaphores
avec l'actuel ministre de l'économie et
des finances monsieur sapin qui dont les
les projets aussi bien sur le budget que
sur le budget de la sécurité sociale le
budget général et le budget de la
sécurité sociale multiplient les
approximations
c'est le haut conseil des finances
publiques qui dénonce avec force
l'un sincérité des comptes et du budget
présenté que ce soit sur la question de
la dette
350 milliards de dettes supplémentaires
depuis 2012 sur la question des impôts
50 milliards d'impôts supplémentaires
depuis 2012
on est en plein dans les fourberies de
sapins sur la question budgétaire sur la
question du budget général sur la
question du budget de la sécurité
sociale puisque quand on entend tout au
long du week-end madame touraine se
réjouir c'est une réjouissance
d'imposture puisque les seuls comptes
redresser le son pour l'assurance
vieillesse uniquement due à la réforme
courageuse du gouvernement sarkozy
fillon de 2010 sur la grande réforme des
retraites et pour le reste ce ne sont
que 15 sincérité et maquillage des
comptes
donc on voit bien que le parti
socialiste est dans une fuite en avant
sur toutes les thématiques que plutôt de
regarder les français dans les yeux pour
leur apporter des réponses concrètes et
courageuse à leurs problématiques
il préfère se regarder le nombril et
donc nous leur demandons nous au nom des
républicains plutôt que de présenter
leur propre candidature à ces primaires
du parti socialiste
et bien qu'ils pensent avant tout à
présenter leurs excuses au peuple
français
compte tenu
du bilan catastrophique qui est le leur
merci et bien pour continuer sur les
errements de ce gouvernement nous
souhaitons revenir sur la situation
d'alstom situation dramatique vous la
connaissez toutes et tous et qui
illustrent au combien le fait qu'aucune
politique industrielle aucune politique
de filière n'a été prise ce gouvernement
au contraire on a l'impression que ce
gouvernement s'est fait un malin plaisir
à désindustrialisé notre pays voire
abandonnées l'intégralité de la filière
sans même revenir sur areva sans même
revenir sur fessenheim et sur la filière
nucléaire qui aujourd'hui est abandonnée
qui n'a plus de lisibilité
on voit bien qu'avec alstom on se
retrouve vraiment dans le néant
politique en matière industrielle et qui
croire on nous dit demain monsieur valls
nous dit que demain
alstom sera sauvé je ne sais pas si
monsieur valls se prend pour
jésus-christ mais en l'espèce ce qui est
certain c'est que nous n'avons pas
vraiment envie quand je dis nous sont
les salariés d'alstom sont les élus du
territoire ce sont les syndicats qui
soit patronaux ou de salariés nous avons
pas vraiment envie de croire en de
vaines paroles voulons des actes
il y a eu de vaines paroles il ya eu ce
monsieur montebourg le ministre
redressement productif qui avait promis
qu'aucun site ne serait fermée et qu'au
contraire mille emplois seraient créés
aujourd'hui sont 400 emplois qui sont
menacés
ça c'est la réalité il y a eu les
promesses de monsieur macron qui du
secrétariat général de l'elysée jusqu'à
sa période de ministre de l'économie
dont personne n'est vraiment certain
qu'il avait compris qu'il était ministre
de l'économie et pas candidat putatif
élections présidentielles s'étaient
aussi engagés sur le site à faire en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de licenciements
aujourd'hui que va-t-il se passer
réellement le site va-t-il être
conservée avec quelle filière avec quels
moyens avec quelle technologie avec
quels contrats publics
voilà ce sont les questions auxquelles
les acteurs locaux salariés les élus ont
besoin de réponses et non pas de
fumeuses promesses qui sont néfastes
pour l'économie française qui sont
néfastes pour les salariés et qui encore
une fois ne permettent pas de redonner
confiance dans un pays qui est un pays
industriel qui est une vraie richesse
qui a un savoir-faire qui a une plus
value à la matière mais qui n'est pas
accompagné et puis dernier sujet que
nous voulions évoquer devant vous en
tant que porte parole compte tenu du
silence assourdissant du gouvernement
socialiste et de françois hollande là
encore il n'aura échappé à personne en
france en europe et dans le monde qui se
produisit un brick site en angleterre il
y a quelques mois à la fin du mois de
juin par la volonté du peuple
britannique
il n'a échappé à personne que tout au
long du week-end à l'occasion du congrès
du parti conservateur le premier
ministre britannique madame mais a
annoncé avec clarté et précision un
calendrier de mise en oeuvre du bric
site au printemps prochain
à la fin du mois de mars et nous sommes
très étonnés
depuis hier de n'entendre personne pas
plus françois hollande que manuel valls
que les responsables du parti socialiste
ou du gouvernement français prendre acte
de ces annonces très clair et d'en tirer
les conséquences et au moins l'une
d'entre elles à la veille du vote du
budget à l'assemblée nationale à un
moment où chaque euro compte
nous souhaitons rappeler gouvernement
socialiste au nom du peuple français que
depuis 1984 et les accords de
fontainebleau la france verse à l'union
européenne
chaque année la somme de 1,6 milliard
d'euros pour garantir le maintien du
royaume uni dans l'union européenne
c'était le fameux chèque ou plutôt
rabais britannique négocié entre
margaret thatcher et françois mitterrand
la fameuse formule à you want my money
back de margaret thatcher
puisque le break si tu rentres en
vigueur dans quelques mois il nous
semble indispensable que la france
entame une procédure vis-à-vis de
bruxelles en disant qu' à compter du
prochain budget celui qui sera votée par
le parlement
le chèque d'1 6 milliard d'euros versée
par la france
chaque année ne le sera plus dorénavant
prenant acte de la décision des
britanniques de quitter l'union
européenne 1,6 milliard d'euros c'est
une somme évidemment considérable pour
nos compatriotes
on pense en particulier pour prendre un
exemple à nos retraités agricoles qu'ils
ouvrent de retraite minimale est
insupportable à allonnes delà du
principe de justice et du travail qui
était le leur tout au long de leur vie
imaginer une seule seconde que nous
ayons la chance d'avoir un président de
la république visionnaire et courageux
qui pourrait demander à bruxelles
la fin de cette mise à disposition d'une
somme conséquente contenu du bric site
et attribuerait dans les meilleurs
délais à l'occasion du budget pourtant
un sincère de monsieur sapin cette somme
à nos retraités agricoles voilà un moyen
très nette est très claire de
réconcilier les français avec la
politique les français avec la puissance
publique les français avec l'europe au
nom du pragmatisme
voilà l'annoncé la proposition que nous
voulions faire aussi avec valérie ce
matin il juste un mot sur l'incapacité
de ce gouvernement et principalement de
son président a porté la parole et un
message de la france on discute
aujourd'hui à l'onu de la décolonisation
de la polynésie française qu'a fait
françois hollande pour éviter ce débat
qu'a fait françois hollande pour faire
en sorte effectivement que une voix
c'est-à-dire quand même celle de la
france puisse être entendue et y
parvenir
dans ce débat strictement rien nous
n'existons plus en europe n'existons
plus à l'international
c'est assez désespérant